what do you make of Louie's case's
findings
well I pay tribute to her she's left no
stone unturned this is an incredibly
broad report and she has found that the
Met can't police itself that it's
failing women that it's moved away from
neighborhood policing and that still
after many years it is yet to rid itself
of institutional racism and sexism and
homophobia it's it's a wake-up call I
think to us all
you've had the commissioner on talking
about the action that he'll be taking
what Dame Luisa said is let's give them
two years to do the things they need to
do to fundamentally change the entire
leadership and structure of the met and
if they haven't done it by that point
then more intervention will be required
but I think it's a really comprehensive
report and government now needs to look
to its role as well let's have those
national standards in terms of vetting
misconduct training that labor has been
calling for for many uh months and that
many reports have been calling for for
many years let's have those national
standards let's bring back neighborhood
policing which is the heart of policing
by consent in our communities and let's
really tackle violence against women and
girls but not just as a slogan put the
resources in to make it happen how
doesn't samark Rowley cherry picking can
know he's saying it's not institutional
even though you said Louise Casey has
gone to a great deal of trouble to point
out that in her opinion it is exactly
the same finding that was found 25 years
ago when you guys were in power when it
was the MacPherson report yes and I
think what um she has said is that uh
institutional racism is still there she
has spent the last year
more than I have more than you have and
she's found that if you're a black
officer for example in the Met you're 81
more likely so she's wrong
I accept the findings of them no no I'm
talking about exceptional findings of
the report he uh uh has said he will
accept the findings of the room no he
didn't he said no he didn't he
absolutely didn't say that he didn't say
that he said he wouldn't accept them in
full I said he said he would accept the
finance of the report I said in full and
he said no well look we can't fiddle
about with the with the language of what
he said he needs to fundamentally change
the cultures and the structures within
the met there are a raft of
recommendations that go to the very
heart of what policing is about and I
think fundamentally what Louise is
saying is that policing attracts the
best of humanity but it will also
attract predators and people who want to
do harm and in the same way that we have
changed systems in education or in
medicine we need to do the same in
policing we need to make sure there
aren't predatory people allowed to exist
in the met and to continue to operate
and be Metropolitan Metropolitan
officers but she's also said we have to
bring back neighborhood policing she
said we have to look at our protection
teams that are
there to solve rape and sexual abuse and
she has offices in her report saying
rape is effectively I understand
decriminalize this is this goes let me
bring you back
he accept the full findings of the
reports yeah absolutely issues except
the findings of the report and my
understanding that he has well he hasn't
because I had him on the program this
morning I didn't that's fine I'm afraid
I have to take my word for it or watch
it back on YouTube he does not accept
the full findings of the report should
he he does he does need to accept the
findings of the report of course she has
spent a year looking at all of these
issues we also think
um that the government need to accept
the refindings and to intervene where
they need to change the law at a
national level because Louise Casey is
really clear she says and she uses the
language austerity has disfigured the
met and she also says that the Met has
walked away from neighborhood policing
in part because of all the cuts that
we've seen so the government needs to
play its role as well national standards
on vetting bringing back neighborhood
policing and tackling violence against
women and girls which are the three
things that labor party would prioritize
because they might really have the full
support of the labor party yes he has
only recently been put in post Louise
Casey supports him completely he was an
assistant commissioner for years well
and then he left and then has come back
in this a lot of these problems were
during his tenure previously let's let's
do what Louise Casey suggests let's give
them time to bring in support to change
those structures but this cannot be
you're absolutely right this cannot be a
report that is allowed to Fester on a
shelf and isn't implemented there are
fundamental changes here that are called
for and Louise Casey says if after two
years changes haven't been made then we
need to look more seriously at
structures within the met we need to
look at systems that operate within
education within the health service
within other public sectors where teams
can be brought in to fundamentally
change what is happening one of the
problems with the system at the moment
is that the inspector will come up with
a report but they have no power to make
sure they're implemented the iopc will
come up with a report they have no power
to make sure it's implemented the mayor
who oversees the role of the Mets also
has very few levers we need to look at
all these things in the round because
this isn't just about the Met as well
and that's really important to say there
are problems across the country
more than half of londoners do not trust
the police and so Mark Rowley this
morning could not tell me whether there
were other rapists within his ranks
I think it is blatantly clear that if
you uh if you are a predator we know
teaching medicine policing you will try
and find places where you can you can
abuse uh vulnerable people we know that
is that clear and we must change that
um uh mindset that says as Louise Casey
says a few times in the report it's not
a few bad apples there is a system that
enables predators to carry on being
police officers and we have to change
that system so we need those standards
it cannot be right that if you've been
accused and you're being investigated
for domestic abuse for example or sexual
abuse you're not automatically suspended
we need to just change that now it
cannot be the case that I could be a
police officer in the met and I'll be
arrested in Essex and the two database
systems don't talk to each other so my
boss is in the Met don't don't know that
I've just been arrested in Essex these
things are fairly simple to change and
we have to change those now because
there will be Predators who try and get
into policing and policing also attracts
the best in humanity and those of
offices need to be able to get on and do
their job they do it's good to see
thanks very much